this is a very interesting story that we
have to talk about Hillary Clinton
decided to go after 2020 Democratic
presidential candidate Tulsi Gabbard
over the weekend Tulsi Gabbard has fired
back and the most important top line
analysis of this entire story is that
this is the best thing to ever happen to
Tulsi Gabbard and I'll explain why
Hillary Clinton did a podcast interview
with David Plouffe who is or Barack
Obama's former campaign manager and
during this interview she made a bunch
of different claims she said the
Russians are leveraging numerous
American politicians Russia may have
compromising information about Donald
Trump she says she believes that 2016
Green Party presidential candidate Jill
Stein is a Russian asset and she
suggested that tulsi gabbard is backed
by Russia and might even be supported by
Russia to run third party in 2020 which
could potentially spoil the election for
the eventual Democratic nominee and help
Donald Trump get reelected as president
of the United States her exact quote is
quote they're also going to do third
party again I'm not making any
predictions but I think they've got
their eye on someone who's currently in
the Democratic primary and are grooming
her to be the third party candidate
she's the favorite of the Russians they
have a bunch of sites and BOTS and other
ways of supporting her so far so this
then sets up tulsi to fire back at
Hillary Clinton in a series of quite
frankly pretty wacky tweets but it
doesn't even matter at this point
because Hillary has stepped in it's so
severely Tulsi Gabbard saying great
Thank You Hillary Clinton you the queen
of warmongers embodiment of corruption
and personification of the rot that a
sickened the Democratic Party for so
long have finally come out from behind
the curtain from the day I announced my
kin that he said the candidacy there has
been a concerted campaign to destroy my
reputation we wondered who was behind it
and why now we know it was always you
through
proxy's and powerful allies in the
corporate media and war machine afraid
of the threat I posed it's now clear
that this primary is between you and me
don't cowardly hide behind your proxies
join the race directly the reason that
this is wacky is the same reason that
tulsi has been wacky wacky all along
which is that tulsi gabbard has been
pretending or claiming that the DNC and
the establishment are stopping her in
the 2020 campaign in the same way that
they stopped Bernie in 2016 this is
delusional and I'll explain why
momentarily but the main point is this
attack by Hillary against Tulsi is the
best thing that has ever happened to her
Tulsi Gabbard has been polling on
average between zero point six and one
point five percent I believe at the
latest she was averaging one point two
percent in the polls she never had a
shot at securing the nomination other
than a few moments and debates she made
Tim Ryan look bad in one debate that's
the one that stands out to me she had a
couple of other moments no traction
other than you know her followers say
she gets a lot of web searches after
debates which doesn't seem to be helping
her polling at all she hasn't even made
all of the debates she's got bad takes
on a lot of issues she's dabbling with
Republican framing all the time check
out her recent interview with cultural
critic Dave Rubin as an example and so
what Hillary Clinton is doing by
attacking Tulsi Gabbard is helping her
fundraising potentially going to help
her polling maybe help her qualify for
the fifth debate in November which she
otherwise may not have as of a few days
ago she had not qualified for it the
tide has been turning more and more
against Tulsi Gabbard because she's
saying more and more ridiculous things
about the kurds and syria and modi and
the DNC and Assad her bogus
grandstanding threat to boycott the
fourth debate which of course she didn't
do it was clear that Tulsi was about to
disappear and in comes Hillary Clinton
and revives attention
for tulsi gabbard a very dumb move now
let me address Tulsi and her followers
framing Tulsi as the screwed candidate
of 2020 just like Bernie was screwed in
2016 this is a ridiculous
comparison there are two main
differences between Bernie 2016 and
Tulsi 2020 and they're not small
differences the differences are public
support and progressive changemakers
okay Bernie Sanders pulled as high as 47
percent in 2016 he had gained the
support of nearly half of the Democratic
primary voters Tulsi Gabbard has not
pulled more than what two in some polls
three maybe in one poll in the entire
primary Tulsi Gabbard does not have and
has never had the support that Bernie
had in 2016 so to equate the campaigns
and to argue that the DNC and
establishment have screwed Tulsi just
like they screwed Bernie out of the
nomination is laughable and anyone who
believes that that is a case that can be
made empirically either doesn't know the
facts or is deliberately not paying
attention to them that's number one
the second difference between Bernie
2016 and Tulsi 2020 is that Bernie's
2016 campaign was a progressive campaign
that actually ran on shaking up the
establishment status quo of campaign
finance of health care on a long list of
issues that have become progressive
mainstream in 2020
Bernie's progressive 2016 candidacy
really threatened the establishment and
changed the way that democratic politics
is done with the huge growth of the
progressive wing of the Democratic Party
Tulsi is running more and more to the
middle she's not for medicare-for-all
she's not clearly even in favor of
impeaching Donald Trump even for the
inquiry she's not clearly for defending
the kurds and on and on and on she's
running on the repeated slogan no more
forever
in a geopolitical vacuum there are
people who have fallen for that and said
that's the progressive hero that's just
that's great that's progressive but the
idea that her campaign is anything like
Bernie's in 2016 in terms of the impact
it would have on the establishment and
the impact that it has on challenging
the status quo is ridiculous but in the
end thanks Hillary Tulsi may now last a
little bit longer
thanks to this entire thing and just yet
another major major misstep by Hillary
Clinton